so robots robots can be programmed to do
the same task millions of times with
minimal error something very difficult
for us right and it can be very
impressive to watch them at work look at
them I mean I could watch them for hours
no well what is less impressive is that
if you take this robot out of the
factories where the environments are not
perfectly known and measure like here to
do even a simple task it doesn't require
much precision and this what can happen
I mean opening a door you don't require
much precision or a small error in the
measurements
it means the valve and let's say in no
way you're recovering most of the time
so why is that well for many years
robots have been designed to emphasize
speed and precision and this translates
in a very specific architecture see the
car robot arm is a very well-defined set
of rigid links and motors what we call
actuators they move the links about the
joints in this a product structure you
have to perfectly measure your
environment so what's is around and you
have to perfectly program every movement
at the robot joints because a small
error can generate a very large force so
you can damage something or you can get
your over damaged if something is harder
so let's stop about a moment and don't
think about the brains of these robots
or our carefully we program them but
rather look at their bodies that's
obviously something wrong with it
because what makes her rubber precise
and strong also makes them ridiculously
dangerous and and effective in the real
world because their body can not deform
or better adjust to the interaction with
the real world so think about the
opposite approach being softer than
anything else around you
well maybe you think that they're not
really a good to do anything yourself
probably well nature teaches the
opposite
for example the bottom of the ocean and
it
of Panda video static pressure a
completely soft animal can move and
interact with a much stiffer object-- on
him he works while carrying around this
coconut shell thanks to the flexibility
of its tentacles which serve as both his
feet and hands and apparently an octopus
cannot soap in a jar that it's pretty
impressive right
but clearly this is not enabled just by
the brain of this anyone but also by his
body and it's a clear example maybe the
clearest example of embodied
intelligence which is a kind of
intelligence that to living organisms
have we all have that our body is shaped
material and structure plays a
fundamental role during the physical
task because we can conform to our
environment so we can succeed in a large
variety of situation without much
planning or calculations ahead so why
don't we put some of these embodied
intelligence into our robotic machines
to release them from relying on
excessive work on composition and
sensing well to do that we can follow
the strategy of nature because with
evolution she's done a pretty good job
in designing machines for an embodiment
interactions and it's easy to notice the
nature uses soft material frequently and
stiff material sparingly and this is
what is done in this new field of
Robotics which is called soft robotics
which the main objective is not to make
super precise machines because we
already they're done but to make robots
able to face unexpected situation in the
real world so able to go out there what
makes a robot soft is first of all is
compliant body which is made of
materials or structures that can undergo
very large deformations
so no more rigid links and secondly to
move them use what we call distributed
actuation so we have to control
continuously the shape of this very
deformable body which as the effect of
having a lot of links and joints but we
don't have any stiff structure at all so
you can imagine that
a soft robot is a very different process
than stiff robotics where you have links
ear screws that you must combine a very
defined way in soft robots you just
build your actuator from scratch most of
the time when you shape your flexible
material to the form in response to a
certain input for example here you can
just a form a structure doing a fairly
complex shape if you think about doing
the same with rigid links and joints and
here what you use just one input such as
air pressure okay well I see some cool
example of soft robots here is a little
cute guy developer Harvard University
and he world thanks to wave so pressure
applied along its body and texture
flexibility can also sneak under a low
bridge keep working and then keep
working a little bit different
afterwards and is a very preliminary
prototype but they also been a more
robust version with power on board that
can actually be sent out in the world
and face real world interaction like a
car passing over keep working cute
or a robotic fish which swims like a
real fish does in water simply because
it has a soft tail we distributed
equation using steel air pressure that
was from MIT and of course we have a
robotic octopus this was actually one of
the first project developed in this new
field of soft robots here you see the
artificial tentacle but they actually
built an entire machine with several
tentacle they could just thrown that in
the water and you see that you can kind
of go around and do submarine
exploration in a very different way that
original school would do but it is very
important for delicate environments such
as color reefs let's go back to the
ground here you see this view from the a
growing robot developed by my colleagues
in Stanford you see the camera fix on
top and this robot is particularly
because using their pressure it grows
from the tip while the rest of the body
stays in firm contact with the
environment and this is aspired by
plants not animals which grows by edema
serialism
in a similar manner so you can face a
pretty large variety of situations but
I'm a biomedical engineer and perhaps
the application I like them all suits
like in the medical field and it's very
difficult to imagine a closer con
interaction with the human body than
actually going inside the body for
example to perform a minimally invasive
procedure and here robots can be very
helpful with the surgeon because they
must enter the body with using small
holes and straight instruments and these
instrument must interact with very
delicate structure in a very uncertain
environment and this must be done safely
also bringing the camera inside the body
so bringing the eyes of the surgeon
inside the surgical field can be very
challenging if you use a realistic like
a classic kind of scope with my previous
research group in Europe we developed
this soft camera robot for surgery which
is very different from a classic
endoscope which can move thanks to the
flexibility of the modules that can bend
and elongate bend in every direction and
also elongates and this was actually
used by surgeons to see what they were
doing with other instruments from
different points of view without caring
that much about what was touched
around
and here you see the soft robot in
action and it just go inside this is a
buddy simulator not a real human body it
goes around you have a light because
usually you don't have too many lights
inside your body we all
but sometimes the surgical procedure can
even be done using a single needle and
instead for now we are working on a very
flexible needle some kind of a very tiny
soft robot which is mechanically
designed to use the interaction with
adhesion steer around inside a solid
organ this makes possible to reach many
different targets such as tumors deep
inside a solid organ by using one single
insertion point and you can either steer
around the structure that you want to
avoid on the way to the target so
clearly this is a pretty exciting time
for robotics we are robots that have to
deal with soft structure so this was
this new and very challenging question
for the robotic community and indeed we
are just starting to learn how to
control how to put sensors on this very
flexible structure but of course we are
not even close to one natural figured
out in millions of years revolutions but
one thing I know for sure the robot will
be softer and safer and there will be
out there helping people thank you
[Applause]